I'd stay later at the hospital and
practice simulation surgery write
research papers all of that's unpaid did
people think when you were a doctor that
you were doing quite well how coming
away of 2,300 it's almost offensively
easy to replace that kind of income been
in property for just over 12 months now
your properties that you're taking on
are big 30 bed HMO net profit that one
will bring in about 15,000 if everybody
who was a doctor came on my crash course
came financially free like you have we'd
be
screwed
Dr Declan Archer yeah all right welcome
to winners on a Wednesday thank you very
much we knew this day would come didn't
we eventually we knew it would happen
been dragged here a little bit but yeah
but you've been so successful and I know
you're you're I don't know if it's your
profession doctors but your whole ways
kind of keep your cars close to your
chest absolutely do you think quietly
absolutely be humble I think be humble
yeah don't don't brag too much and work
on it in the background but you've
achieved so much much just tell us in a
nutshell then we can break it down but
what have you achieved in the last year
or so in property yeah so kind of been
in property for I guess just over 12
months now um in terms of what I
achieved so service accommodations is
primarily what I've been doing at the
moment um rent to service accommodation
and Le opson to service the
accommodation so have five of those at
the moment um and then have started
branching out into the social housing
space as well just CU that kind of
aligns with what I care about a little
bit more yeah um as much as I like the
holiday service accommodation side um
yeah in terms of what I what matters to
me I think social housing is where I
want to go and and your your properties
that you're taking on are big so you say
I've got five this and let's just talk
about the scale that's thing like the
last deal that you got yeah so so more
recently they're becoming big um classic
economies of scale it actually just
makes Financial sense to take of stuff
so like 30 units um being the the
largest that I officially have and then
there's a lot of negotiations for 59
units which hopefully will be coming
pretty
soon and then even higher than where is
that one that you've got that's a
middlesbor midb up in the northeas units
and what is it converted care home so
it's like a 30 bed HMO um with 12 shared
bathrooms do you rent to rent it or have
you got the option to buy it so that
one's just a commercial lease I was
actually offered the potential for
release option but it's not really in
the area that I would want to have
particular ownership over the property
um so kind of went for a commercial
lease rather than a lease option with
that one I mean it's five years long so
there's scope for discussions further
down the line if it's what I think how
much does that one make a month uh so
net profit that one will bring in about
15,000 15 grand a month profit that's
just incredible man yeah yeah absolutely
incredible and the lease options you've
got two lease options yeah so got a four
bedroom house in Gates head which is
just over the I know it very well yeah
um and then also have a two-bedroom
flatten an era called BL which is like
North umland just north of uh Newcastle
uh both of those kind of serves
accommodation mainly for construction so
there's ridiculous amounts of work going
on in like Central Newcastle for
construction work um and then there's a
reasonable amount in North umland as
well um with like wind farms being made
and stuff and now your thing is you're
looking to take on more blocks yeah I
think so I think when you just look at
you know it's it's quite interesting you
I mean I had trouble getting my first
rent to rent and know their
three-bedroom house and you look at the
amount of work that goes into getting
one of those versus the amount of work
and taking on a 30 unit converted Care
Home the difference isn't huge I mean
there's a little bit more pieces to you
know work around and yeah it's it's a
bit more complicated on the legal side
yeah it can get a little bit Messier and
trying to align contracts so that it's
secure for me as well as you know the
different social housing groups and that
that I'm kind of working with but like
it's certainly not 30 times as difficult
I mean I said this to my brother
recently we we just bought a hotel yeah
and we bought the hotel business and the
hotel building the free hole building
yeah in my paperwork I was having to go
through we're also getting a mortgage as
well on the property a commercial
mortgage and I was having to like s you
know apply for the mortgage this sign
this the lease the hotel all this
paperwork and I was going through and I
was thinking gez I mean as it happens we
can make a lot of money off of this
hotel if this was just a house yeah a
200 Grand it's not worth it yeah the
paper might be a bit less it's not worth
it even bother buying it just the so so
and this is one of the things I learned
which you've applied very much to your
to your your property business which is
if you're going to grow and scale a
business rather than growing in terms of
number of properties and number of deals
oh I did 10 deals last year next year
I'm going to do 100 it's much better to
say I did 10 deals last year I'm going
to do five next year but they're going
to be 20 times as big absolutely and
grow that why yeah it just financially
makes sense as well I mean your
overheads end up being quite scary cuz
they are quite abely but if you break it
down in terms of number of units
actually your overheads compared with
taking on you know say one bedroom Flats
as rent to rents your overheads are
actually quite significantly smaller so
and and that's where the profits made is
basically through classic economies of
scale and the reduced overhead do you
have any blocks on lease options or your
lease options no so no so the lease
options are literally a four-bedroom
house and a two-bedroom flat right um
but the block that I'm currently
negotiating which is which is well it's
basically 12 apartment but 59 on Suite
rooms um so that's I'm trying to get
that as a least option so it's looking
like it's going to come off I'm hoping
so yeah um again there's lots of
different you know pieces to the puzzle
but I mean the the Crux is it's a a
block where the person wants to sell
within 5 years they want 35,000 a month
for it the numbers make sense at that
point I don't really see yeah why not um
and you know if it's a commercial leas
I'm happy with that anyway and again it
gives you that time where maybe you know
take it on as a commercial leas over 5
years but at 12 months let's negotiate
oh do you want to sell in the next four
years or whatever and then convert to
Rel lease option there so what kind of a
doctor are you um so I eye surgery is my
specialty um I have slightly took a step
back from that so as well as doing that
I do kind of General emergency medicine
and stuff like that as well just to so
you're still practicing doctor yeah yeah
I mean not not fulltime or anything it
would be probably average as like two
days a week sort of thing did were you
full-time a year ago um yeah so I left
full-time work in February right and
because of the property stuff yeah nice
yeah yeah yeah it's yeah is nice do you
know what doctors work so many hours
it's ridiculous oh my goodness I was I
was at the um my wife had to have a a
small surgery yeah last month and the
doctor that I was had been working since
7:00 a.m. I said what time did you
finish he said it'll be about 8 9:00 in
the evening yeah yeah I thinking how can
you work 14 hours with that much
concentration as a doctor and he was
just oh it's normal yeah it's normally
he's probably not been paid for a lot of
those hours as well and then he'll go
home and he'll have XY Z all that stuff
so I'd go home and well I'd stay late at
the hospital and practice simulation
surgery had then go home and write
research papers CU that's what you need
to do and then also trying to develop
clinically you know your knowledge on
the side and so and all of that's unpaid
so it was just wow exhausting have you
replaced your income already yeah yeah
so you're earning now you replaced your
yeah I mean po I mean post tax and
University debt I was coming away of
2,300 2,400 a month jeez yeah so it's
almost offensively easy to replace that
kind of income 2,300 as a doctor working
crazy hours yeah yeah Base hours 40 a
week you work youing for the NHS yeah
yeah it's pretty difficult to not work
for the NHS in the UK unfortunately at
least Madness until you're a consultant
and then have the what a skilled job
though and you had to go to un pres yeah
so yeah got four degrees um five years
medicine and Masters in the middle of
medicine have done two additional
degrees alongside work how much did all
of your your your training cost for to
be a doctor um I'm in about £80,000 of
University debt how can you spend
£80,000
training and then be making 2,300 that
that blows my mind yeah it blows my mind
as as well it's it's kind of a reality
that not not many people who apply for
are aware of and I think in the UK as
well you know I have this perception of
well you shouldn't be doing it for money
but you know I mean um no but you need
to be paid for what you're doing yeah
exactly and you know I'm counselor State
lad my parents rent a council house and
you know the thought is well at least
when I was applying is hopefully this
will be a career work and support them
whatever and then you realize you're
actually kind of struggling financially
did people think when you were a doctor
did people assume that you were doing
quite well financially yeah they assume
you're at least double what you're
making yeah oh I did I until now I KN
you I didn't know B salary is a
Opthalmic surgeon as a trainee you know
I was on 42,000 b s yeah but then you've
got as you mentioned you've got your and
then you've got all the other stuff Tax
your debts yeah yeah and then all the
free work on the side as well so yeah it
just yeah absolutely exhausting I think
I did quite a lot when I was at
University I was fairly high achiev and
got a pretty damn hard job to get so I
think I kind of realized what the
reality of the future career was going
to be and not many people are very happy
you know the the surgeons who you going
and see who probably did your wife
surgery is probably not that happy so
it's not really where I want I said to
him and now I regret saying it cuz when
he told me how how many hours he was
working I said oh well I hope you
getting paid well and he just didn't he
didn't just didn't say it you just you
know yeah you probably thinking nope
really absolutely he's probably on 25 a
sh really cuz we need doctors everybody
who was a doctor came on my crash course
m joined the academy became financially
free like you have we'd be screwed
absolutely yeah we need doctors I
completely agree um yeah it's
frustrating cuz unfortunately I've kind
of got to the point where I'm just like
that's not my problem
there's many many of my friends are just
exhausted with it all burnt out do they
want to get into property now too or you
secret so I haven't kept it as much of a
secret from them they're quite
encouraging and they're interested
investing and stuff with me um I think
most of them want an Exit Plan not no
one's going into medicine with the
intention of that being their long-term
career anymore and most of them are
either going into GPS where you have a
bit more flexibility where you can teach
and stuff as well or others are kind of
planning their exit route but taking
that jump from something that you've
committed to for so long is really quite
your stuff though that you've been doing
like rent to rent service accommodation
lease option agreements it's quite hard
work it's it's not like investing in
property where you've got a couple
hundred grand you just buy a house and
rent it out that's not that difficult
that's quite easy but going out like
you've done and securing lease
options that's like time consuming so
how did you manage to do that whilst
being a doctor yeah so I mean like
everyone says you know in your evenings
and stuff luckily like gum tree open
rent Facebook Marketplace you know the
24/7 things they're not kind of confined
to I guess I haven't used estate agents
probably as much as other people because
I didn't have the time during 9 till 5
to be able to make all of these calls so
a lot of them were pretty much like off
Market sort of stuff who I'd go see them
if I had a Saturday off um and then a
component of my job as well as doing the
eye surgery was like research which
gives you a little bit more flexibility
so um I had two days a week of doing
research and you say researching
property deals does that count I mean it
gives you a bit of flexibility doesn't
it so I dope work from home cuz you
don't got the travel and all the exactly
so it was that sort of thing so I guess
it was a little bit fortunate there
where you know I'd spend my evenings
writing up research papers and could
give myself a morning to try and do some
property stuff so just worked it around
that largely and then yeah since
February I've pretty much been fulltime
with a bit of Lo and work here and then
talk to me about for anyone who doesn't
know the power of lease option what is a
purchase lease option and how can you
buy properties using no money on leas
option agreements You' done it so I mean
I think the power from my perspective is
you know you can take on a property
without having to put much up
financially um and you have the
exclusivity to purchase it in the future
um you then use it for cash flow or you
kind of cross your fingers or look at
the market research and hope that
capital appreciation comes with it and
then you're technically buying blue
market value and then I think what's
often not talked about is well what's
actually the power of it for the seller
so it's often finding people who are in
real difficulties and you're actually
providing iding a solution to them um so
like for example the flap that I've took
on this was a guy who was just renting
out a private tenant um and the last two
times he's done that they've trashed his
flat so he this was literally a Facebook
Marketplace message but met with him and
he was just I never want to rent to a
private tenant ever again they keep
trashing all my stuff trying to kick
them out as impossible and it's actually
costing me more money because I'm want
to do a full referb after each six
months on the leave um so basically I
was able to come to him and say well how
about my company takes it on he has my
credibility based on XY Z that I've
already done and I'll also purchase it
for it was a negative equity with it as
well um so let me purchase it to solve
that negative equity problem but equally
I'll look after it I'll do the
maintenance in the meantime and this is
where I'll get my profit so great for me
but I think the main thing with lease
options is you're actually providing a
solution I don't really think it works
unless you've got an amazing
relationship with you know a portfolio
landlord I don't think it works unless
you're really solving someone's big
problem it doesn't work yeah and and
least option agreement is the kind of
thing where you need to have it in your
pocket don't you it's not going to work
for everybody a lot of people that are
selling their houses they need the money
to move on with their life or they need
the money to reinvest in another
property yeah that's not going to work
cuz if you say I'll buy off here in
seven years time they're like well no I
need the money now but your guy he
didn't have any Equity because he bought
it in it a dip so even if he sold it now
he'd make nothing yeah and he the
property was a liability to him cuz he
he'd be mismanaging get had issues with
tenants so you're now saying I'll rent
it through a company if I don't pay the
rent you can kick me out within 7 Days
exactly you're going to get full rent
and I'll buy it off you in how many how
many years um so the flat is four years
four years yeah nice yeah I mean I've
I've struggled to find longer ones like
s 10 years I remember when I bought one
for seven years I agreed to buy it after
seven years yeah cuz I didn't have any
money yeah and then it shot up in value
yeah and then the sell's like M and
that's he asked me in the sixth year he
said can we have a coffee and I thought
I know where this is going yeah cuz
that's the thing you know with Rel lease
option agreement if it goes up in value
you have the option to buy not the
obligate you don't have to buy if it
goes up that's your capital appreciation
there yeah you know yeah and I guess
sometimes they might just need a
reminder of well I've actually got you
out of this real difficulty that you are
having and were they repres by sisters
your guys yeah yeah so it's it's all
been done good yeah that's another thing
if my guy had a said to me can we have a
coffee or and then basically I don't
want to sell it to you for the price
that we agreed yeah if we hadn't have
had a seller sorry a solicitor
representing him he could have just said
I didn't know what I was signing exactly
yeah and then I've lost all that capital
appreciation yeah so even I mean I PID
solicit fees for one of mine but I just
think you know it's it's even you know
you're pay an extra 1,500 whatever up
front but you're securing that yourself
yeah um so yeah I think they're a great
strategy I think they're a great
strategy at the moment is as well I mean
I've got a negotiation of a hell of a
lot of them at the moment cuz I just
feel people aren't wanting to drop the
prices as much as you know to get a good
Ballo market value they because of the
way the market is but then well they
either have to or they have to wait for
the price that they want don't and I
think people are increasingly realizing
they have all these liabilities mortgage
bills whatever and rather than taking a
big 25% belue market value cash offer
unless they're really really really
desperate and really need that cash they
would rather wait so I'm actually
finding more people are almost like
proposing a lease option to me when I'm
there having a chat with them yeah it's
really quite a year and a half ago de it
wasn't that tool it was actually hard
getting a leas option because a year and
a half ago people could just say like
that yeah but now because of interest
rates because it's more of a buyer
Market there's people that have got
their house on the market it's been on
the market for six months yeah yeah yeah
what's the clever way that you do to
find your lease
options um so I guess the main way is
kind of post Auction Direct vendor
letters talk to me about that strategy
yeah so I mean initially kind of started
thinking about that um when I was
looking to do a bit of property trading
which is quite interesting to me you
know finding stuff that's marketed
poorly that hasn't sold at auction get a
below market value purchase and then
just sell without actually doing stuff
with a bit of extra market and that was
the main reason but again I found people
really reluctant to drop the price and
the reason I kind of found things
weren't selling at auction was because
people weren't willing to take that type
of discount they were guided too high
inappropriately whatever so I just
started reaching out to you know things
that hadn't sold on two to three Cycles
at auction sending them a letter saying
you know there's a potential way that I
might be able to help solve your problem
can we have a chat and that's that's
actually been really really effective is
that how you got both of your deals no
no actually um that's the way I'm there
there's one they going through legals at
the moment that's how I got that one um
and it's brought a lot of leads and I've
had many conversations where you know
I'm hoping to secure more through that
and the ones previously were basically
what was it um one actually one was at
auction it wasn't with a post auction
offer I can't actually remember how I
did that one um but the the other one
was Facebook Marketplace and the thing
is as well like if people haven't got
money and they want to own a lot of
properties but they haven't got 100
Grand here 100 Grand there having a
lease option it's almost as good as
buying cuz all the capital appreciation
is yours yeah absolutely you can buy it
at the end and you can then as you said
you can rent it out and save the cash
flow as the deposit yeah AB absolutely
or buy it on a bridge at the end or
there's so many there's so many things
you can do yeah or you know even the
potential to add value during that
period so almost doing a br without
having to put through the deposit as
long I mean getting financing on that's
a little bit more challenging but as
long as you can get investor financing
to fund your BR then if you can actually
take it on as a lease option add value
to it then you don't necessarily have to
wait that far 5e period why don't you
exit it early then you have ownership of
it and you've uplifted the value so it's
basically like I think an umbrella where
you can utilize all the different
strategies within that but without
having to put up a huge amount of money
up front do you worry when you take on a
whole block that you're not going to be
able to rent it out and you're going to
be absolutely screwed because if you're
renting out one little apartment yeah
not only do you know it's going to work
yeah but also if it doesn't work it's
only a grand a month yeah you can cancel
your brake claw
you can it's not whereas if you've got
like 20 30 40 50 all in one block seems
like a huge risk yeah um so it depends
on your exit really I mean my exit is
basically emergency housing for
vulnerable people through a variety of
um social housing groups which are
mainly home office funded um so it's
actually fairly guaranteed for me to be
honest with you tell me then tell me
tell me like that that that block that
you got yeah talk to me about the
structure of that and who you're renting
it to yes so I mean that was literally
found on right move there was um rooms
all individually for rent looked that'
all been kind of painted in the same way
but were slightly different so I just
kind of spoke to the agent and was like
you know I say there's a lot of rooms in
this block as the scope to take on the
whole thing um they kind of weren't done
up to a a great standard they were
initially intended to be student
accommodation but you know students have
fairly High demands for the quality of
their accommodation now so it wasn't
going to get the rent that they wanted
um so I kind of looked it and thought
well maybe I can be the one person that
provide a solution here cuz they've been
trying to rent these for ages they'
missed the student Market as well in
September so all the students in midb
tside un whatever it's called had
already got their accommodation sorted
so this landlord was kind of there with
kind of suboptimal accommodation and
with no one to rent it to so I kind of
thought what's what's the potential
solution to that and I'd built
relationships with a bunch of social
housing providers in the Northeast for
quite a while took them for coffees said
what my career was that my aim was you
know to provide good high quality
accommodation to vulnerable people um is
there a way that we can kind of work
through this and then through
conversations cuz initially it was you
know buy a house rented out to a family
for 5 years on an F lease through
whatever social housing group but then
through conversations basically found
out that they all also do have a
component which is emergency housing
which is basically slightly lower than
service accommodation rates but still
guaranteed monthly for a 5year period
wow yeah so ridiculous so really it's
your connections then absolutely I mean
I no I probably 9 months of having
conversations with no particular like
Financial intention from my side just
you know I want to work with these type
of people I want to provide
accommodation for from the landlord's
perspective he's really happy cuz he's
got guaranteed rent well yeah so it's
basically a rent to rent so uh I'm
basically the middle man so I'm giving
the landlord Market rent which he would
not be able to achieve from anyone else
and 30 better um so he's making
fantastic money you know about 120,000 a
year which otherwise was sap doing
nothing um and then basically subletting
it to a large social housing provider at
I mean that one's £47 per night per room
what kind of contracts do you need then
for this so a commercial lease with the
landlord and then basically the social
housing groups have their own specific
contracts um and we through a little bit
of negotiation from isol liters on their
side basically refine them so they're
fair cuz they are generally a little bit
more tailored towards helping out the
social housing group they typ typical
one so a little bit of negotiation there
just to kind of make sure everybody's
happy that's what you get paid for yeah
yeah has it made you rethink your entire
business plan in terms of property are
you now just thinking I just want to be
renting to housing associations uh yeah
rent and housing associations on an
emergency basis um cuz you know it's
it's providing the perfect solution
landlords want good guaranteed Rend
social housing groups aren't taking on
these hotels and stuff which is kind of
suboptimal accommodation for for people
anyway um so it's pretty much being the
middleman doing all of the you know
contracts with cleaning all the
maintenance all the headache basically
which can be systemized quite nicely
though um and then taken the fee in the
middle so socializing group doesn't want
to deal with all that headache the
landlord doesn't want to deal with all
that headache but wants a good guant
rent I'm happy to deal with and
systemize the headache but then take a
fee in the middle so now you're looking
for small apartment blocks um I'm
looking for 50 plus unit apartment
blocks really um Nationwide
predominantly Northeast at the moment um
but also kind of Midlands Northwest when
you were talking to um housing
associations and you were kind of doing
all your networking what was what were
they how how were you received and what
were you saying to them yeah so and
initially it's really difficult to get
to the right person I mean oh you
generally find as well with these groups
that it's you know one employee doing
three people's jobs so I think you
really need to demonstrate I guess your
credibility um that you have the right
intentions you know my intention
obviously is to build a sustainable
profitable business from it but my
intention is also to provide vulnerable
people with good high quality
accommodation you know putting a library
in the one in Middlesboro to help you
know this will probably be mainly for
Asylum Seekers but to help them you know
learn English to integrate in the
society to be able to contribute to
society more so I think that's kind of
what got me the good connections and
kind of got my foot in the door and
almost a degree of exclusivity because
with this current block that I'm
negotiating I do know someone else has
took the same block to the company and
they called me and basically said we
kind of want to just work with you
because we no I mean it probably helps
that I'm a doctor but you know want to
help out vulnerable people and you know
you've got the credibility because
you've done this before use the doctor
card a bit when you're talking to I
Really Don't to be honest I don't
everywhere it's I've never introduced
myself as a as
Doctor de that's all my name is Dr deck
good to me did I tell you I'm a Doctor
by the way that be me I mean it probably
hopefully brings a bit of
professionalism a bit of credibility
espcially when you're when you're
talking about housing vulnerable people
and emergency accommodation I think it's
I think I guess I use it when I feel
it's relevant so you know to do a rent
to rent with service accommodation
unless it's for healthcare professionals
it's always relevant bro you're a doctor
it's always relevant you spent 80 grand
for that that training well exactly for
those two letters um I guess I'm just
try to bring a bit of humility in it as
well but I I kind of get what you're
saying and I I probably should do it a
little bit more um but particularly in
the social housing space hopefully it
does demonstrate so what is it then so
what do they exactly do the the the
housing associations and how do they get
paid how do they get paid so well I mean
the specific ones that I'm working with
how do they get paid while the home
office has a PO of money that's
allocated by po and it's yeah it is a
big pot um and that's money that you
know and so if if we're talking
specifically about Asylum Seekers
although my intention is to Branch out
and help you know homeless people with
specific Healthcare needs whatever but
if we're talking specifically about you
know home office funded um social
housing groups uh for Asylum Seekers you
know there's a pot of money that's there
which needs to be utilized by
international law these people have to
be housed in good high quality
accommodation
um so I mean that's their pot of money
that's how they get paid um in terms of
how I get paid it's by basically you
know they have emergency accommodation
and then it branches out into different
houses for longer term accommodation so
it basically is a service accommodation
business but specifically just for the
home office so they have their pot of
money they need to utilize it we have
these people by international law who we
need to protect and provide good high
quality accommodation but dealing with a
big massive surfice accommodation unit
is not what these social housing groups
want to be doing and equally most people
the landlords can't be bothered with all
of that hassle too so you know from the
landlord's perspective it would imagine
how much time you spend back and forth
with the contracts also if there's any
problems you'll have to deal with it
yeah yeah they need 24-hour security the
need 24 maintenance yeah did you find
that that the housing associations that
you were speaking to did they all want
big stuff or did some of them CU I rent
a lot of my four five bed six bed hmos
yeah Housing Association I've even got
houses I've even got like two bed houses
so for for emergency housing they need
big stuff um for kind of standard 510
some 25 year F leases well will give you
just above Market rent would you
consider investing in blocks yourself
buying a block and renting it to the
Housing Association yeah yeah I mean
ideally through Le off agreements um
because I mean I do think that kind of
provides the solution to the landlord as
well because you can give them a bit of
a higher price than they could get for
now um and equally you know give them a
few years to have some good rental
income coming through too um but then is
great for me cuz I don't have to put
down bloody several hundred thousands
which I don't but how much would it cost
to buy a block in the Northeast the 30
better was up for 1.1 million and but
that's only you only have to put down
30% yeah yeah yeah you know few hundred,
thousand yeah and then you'd own it you
would
um I think for me personally I I would
rather go down the lease option way I
don't I think what's really interesting
about lease options with larger things
is you don't hit the same kind of like
reluctancy that if you were wanting to
take on a two-bedroom flat cuz you know
that's from so right that's like a
family who has an emotional relationship
with it 100% I I secured a hotel the sh
on a leas option agreement and when I'm
approaching hotels or commercial
properties or they get it yeah you don't
even have to suggest it to you yeah they
to sell it to them yeah you just even if
you ring up an agent a commercial agent
you can just say would they consider an
option yeah and they'll be like probably
would let me speak to them but if you
say that about a small house or
residential apartment what yeah you're
never getting through yeah absolutely so
it's it's purely business and I actually
think most people would want to have
that guaranteed rental income let me
kind of see and the higher and the
higher profit at the end as well um so
it's I mean everything's win-win isn't
it also another little tip um is if you
see on commercial property says all
inquir is welcome yeah that means we'll
do a leaste option yeah yeah you know so
the biggest thing then for you the
biggest asset you have is your network
absolutely yeah I guess Network and
knowledge um and knowledge yeah cuz God
I mean if if you ever suggested two
years ago to attempt to take on things
that of this sort of size it's sounds
absolutely ridiculous um that's funny
though that you say that yeah yeah I
mean in such a short period of time to
pinch yourself sometimes um I think yeah
it is just a bit like like how do I have
the balls to go for these kind of things
you know what I mean but it once you've
kind of run the smaller units you do
actually realize that it is very doable
um so I think I would yeah I mean
knowledge is the main thing you can't
always find your own deals but I mean in
terms of network how important you're a
doctor so you're you believe in
education you spent 80 grand on your
education yeah how important is the
academy and investing in that Network
and knowledge being to help you with
your property J absolutely essential
really isn't it I mean I I particularly
think the mentorship cuz even when I was
trying to you know secure three bed
house rent to rents there's no way that
I would have been able to have done it
appropriately legally ticked off all the
boxes had the right contracts in place
without being able to run things by
people even now I mean God I mean I'm
very new to it I say even now but you
know in 5 years time I still think
having an experienced person to bounce
things off is just incredibly important
go to my you know profession being a
doctor it's very rare that we make a
decision on our own you know I'll speak
to some other doctors and be like this
is a little bit complicated what's your
thoughts on this what's your thoughts on
this what's the best way to approach it
I think when you're trying to do large
things and trying to do them creatively
having a variety of different people
with different experiences to be able to
bounce ideas off right and for them to
say actually yeah this does make sense
why don't you go for that it's like is
well I use doctor you may have even
heard me when I'm when I'm selling the
Academy I even say I say look if you
want to be a doctor yeah you have to go
to university yeah if you don't why is
someone going to tr no one would trust
you with surgery on your eye yeah if you
said don't worry I've watched a lot of
YouTube videos right so if they're not
going to trust you with their eye why
should someone entrust you with their
apartment block building yeah if you've
not got properly trained yeah absolutely
why would someone invest in you if you
aren't prepared to invest in yourself
you know doesn't make any sense 100% And
I think think like particularly when
you're dealing with commercial agents
and stuff like that who know what
they're talking about you look like an
idiot yeah if you if you're trying to
like BS your way through that they'll
see you straight through it so I think
being it's embarrassing oh yeah and
they'll never work with you ever again
if you like that or if you dodge you or
whatever so I think being able to like
have the knowledge articulated to
someone in the field who knows what
they're talking about that builds your
credibility so even this you know block
that I'm hoping to take on soon had a
chat with the agent he was like even if
this falls through you know I think we
should work together on this that's
great when that happens yeah cuz he's
you know all he does is apartment blocks
that's his entire agency so it's that
kind of credibility and that knowledge
um which I think builds those
relationships which actually allows you
to have a sustainable business rather
than just like a a waroff let's make a
quick book from this sort of thing so so
none of the housing associations that
you spoke to are looking for small
houses or so they are um but not on
emergency housing rates okay so
typically you know they'll give you a
five 10 year F lease and about Market
rent sometimes a little bit lower than
Market rent cuz they deal with all the
maintenance stuff whereas the emergency
housing is I mean the intention is
people come in for a few days and then
get allocated to these family houses how
much how sorry how big would the block
need to be for them to be interested so
minimum 50 units Now 50 yeah so kind of
purpose built student blocks or
apartment
blocks so that's that's what I'm that's
almost exclusively and how much would
they renting for what about like you
know my apartment block a 50 in wolver
Hampton okay yeah how much would there
so gen gen I mean there's a lot of
conversations about okay well where can
the numbers work so your margin is
worthwhile you I'll get if I rent that
out as a normal um a contract talking
about
78900 an apartment okay if I do it for
service accommodation obviously it' be
more the problem with service to
accommodation is there's 50 yeah you're
competing with each other yeah it's is
the demand big enough in wampton
absolutely I mean generally what I find
is it's about kind of 10 to 15 I mean
don't quote me on this cuz each one's
different and there's conversations that
you know make sure it's worthwhile for
everyone um but kind of 10 to 15 below
service accommodation nightly rates but
okay but 100% occupancy so it might be
about 70 pound a night something like
that yeah for so for the ones that I'm
looking at so a couple Grand a month
probably I'll qu I'll quote you on that
couple now there's many factors yeah
yeah so I mean so the ones that I'm take
the one I have is 47 pound per night
room the other one's looking about 54
that's below Market service
accommodation that rate you more more
than double what you get as an EST yeah
pretty much especially if you're in
somewhere like in Middlesboro cuz in
middlesbor for an apartment you ain't
going to get more than about 5 600 Quid
yeah about 600 yeah so that's incredible
I mean that's that's how you really
maximize your profits yeah um but then
equally provide a good service for it as
well so yeah and it you have to be able
to I mean there's so much h associated
with it at least up front and your
overheads are so high your margin has to
be worth it and they do understand that
so 100% occupied though that's the big
thing isn't it that's huge yeah it's
pretty much a guaranteed rent to a rent
to rent and then subl to another
guaranteed rent yeah and take the profit
with well that's how I got into soci
social housing about four five years ago
one of my
students called Andy pitched me on a
rent to rent on one of my hmos okay and
he was offering an amount and I thought
dude how you going to make money yeah
yeah how you going to make money and he
said social housing yeah and I thought
all right so he took it off me rented it
to me and then he passed it to Housing
Association he don't make a lot of money
on it no but for him it's it's very much
passive it's hands off isn't it and he
he might have made £300 a month from it
but it's hands off guaranteed for he's
had it the whole time he's had it he's
had it he's had it for about five six
years yeah yeah something like that and
then we then started going direct to
housing associations and now my parents
have even got their own Housing
Association which is cool but that's
based that's based in booking and Ma do
them that's that's interesting yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean yeah I think I'm
thinking of buying something just for
them yeah it Mak sense yeah absolutely I
mean it's a great way to do things I
think it is about being a credible
landlord though and cuz I think often
you know you find that some landlords
might give suboptimal accommodation I
think it's really now that they are
making sure that people are being given
good high quality accommodation so it's
almost like lifting up the standard for
what social housing should be which is
exactly what they're more picky now than
they were a few years ago before housing
associations were desperate for houses
but I think people are beginning to
cuton on and now people are get it's a
bit of a sexy subject now isn't it
social housing so you have to you have
to run it as a a good reputable business
rather than just he has some houses
Chuck some people in it what do you mean
by that though so as in I think the pure
reason why I'm building those
relationships with the social housing
groups is because of my credibility what
I've done so far that I'm providing high
quality accommodation that I'm
passionate about trying to build the
community how do they know that because
of what I've demonstrated in this so you
show them your other properties I've
show them what I've done I've show them
this 30 better that I'm taking um okay
so you're talking about if you're trying
to do rent to rent Housing Association
and you go in and you're pitching to
housing associations and supported
living companies but you're brand new
you've got no experience you got no
training they're just going to think a
yeah I think so I you were speak the
wrong people anyway yeah I mean I was
like I say it took N9 months for me to
be be able to build up the relationships
that I have and that was all through
kind of credibility I think that's
allowed me to kind of have do you plan
on continuing being the doctor is that
the plan um PL well so plan is probably
continue do a few shifts here and there
just to M my license I mean the end goal
is you know have a charity ideally
internationally and provide free health
care but kind of need to sort out you
know my have we already family called
NHS um not not well not too much
internationally I think what I find is
so I I'm very interested in global
health and the problems particularly
when you look at eye surgery and stuff
you know you'll have a lady who's 40
years old who's had a cataract since she
was born she's never seen her kids never
been able to contribute to their local
economy whereas we operate on people who
are very minor eye problems here in my
opinion so my kind of if I'm looking at
it in terms of where I think I can add
the most benefit well if you operate on
somebody in subsaharan Africa allow them
to see from the age of six rather than
40 then their entire work in life they
can then get a job contribute to society
you know did you see that Mr Beast video
which one where know honestly I can't
remember the he paid for an x amount of
like a million people to be able to see
that's cool isn't it it's very cool I
think it's partly because it was in
America though and I I do think we are
quite fortunate as much as the NHS is
sometimes is often a challenge for its
employees um I think we are incredibly
lucky to
have pretty much free at the point of
view Healthcare the reason he had to pay
for so many people's cataracts I don't
know if it was in America I think it
might have been across Africa I was it
well it was somewhere where it wasn't a
public health a publicly funded service
so you know you can go and get a
cataract surgery in a few months is that
what you really feel passionate about
then you feel passionate about setting
up health care for specifically people
that can't see very well or can't see at
all yeah get an eye surgery for them
pretty much that's awesome yeah I mean
that's the aim I love that Vision yeah
I'm down to donate to that thank you I'm
down to donate to that well hey it's
been a real pleasure yeah um final words
of wisdom or advice people wanting to
get into property but maybe they're busy
doctors professionals yeah I think you
know it's it's hard work initially it is
a bit of a SLO um there's lots of news
which is really quite interesting coming
from like being at like a reasonably
well respected profession to then being
told no stop talking to me by all these
agents um but you kind of just have to
push through it and I think also like
you can actually really improve people's
lives by providing good high quality
accommodation and making a profit from
it on the side so you can do you can do
a lot of good I've really enjoyed this
interview and I love what you say about
going from a doctor well respected to
going out with agents it's so true yeah
everyone's on the same you can get on
the academy you got a guy here who's 17
years old absolutely who's got bad
credit who's and then you've got a
lawyer and they're on the same yeah yeah
they're both they're all it's like when
you when you playing the board game you
go back to square one yeah yeah it's
quite humbling actually I actually
really liked it it's nice to to grind
again and um and yeah overcome those
challenges well you doing super well I
really appreciate no thanks so much
for